Let's consider another system of equations. When we perform substitution, we
need to choose one variable and one of the equations that is easiest to solve
for. For example, in this equation, we want to think, is it easier to get x
alone, or y alone? Also, we could consider the other equation. Do we want to
solve for this x, or this y? We need one of these equations to be in the form, x
equals something, or y equals something in order to perform substitution. So,
what do you think in this case? Which of these variables would be easiest to
solve for? Choose the best one. If you actually solve for some of these
variables, you might see that some are better than others. Think about why that
is. Maybe some have negatives. Maybe some have fractions. You want the easiest
one.